here with reaction Texas Senator Ted
Cruz Senator how are you
great to see you Senator all right first
of all great job yesterday
um that's why Alan dershowitz says you
were one of the best Debaters students
he's ever had in this Harvard Law class
but in all seriousness here they have
done everything they can do to obstruct
James Gilmer's investigation into the
Biden family this is a this is a witness
that the FBI paid hundreds of thousands
of dollars to in the past for Intel
they've had this now for years why have
they sat on it
well but I I believe because they're
covering up look the the FBI at that
hearing yesterday that deputy director I
asked him directly did they have did the
1023 allege that Biden had received a a
personal bribe of five million dollars
he refused to answer I asked him will he
will the FBI give the 1023 to the Senate
Judiciary Committee he refused to answer
I asked him is it accurate that there
are 17 voice recordings of this Barista
official 15 talking to Hunter Biden two
talking to Joe Biden he refused to
answer I asked him does the FBI have
those 17 voice recordings he refused to
answer I asked him will the FBI give to
the Senate Judiciary Committee those 17
voice recordings so we can assess for
ourselves he refused to answer they are
utterly and completely stonewalling and
what's important to know there's no
legal impediment to his answering my
question there's no legal barrier he's
simply sitting there with that smug
smirk on his face because the FBI senior
leadership believes they're
unaccountable they're not accountable to
Congress they're not accountable to the
American people and these allegations
if true
Biden should be impeached he should be
removed from office he should be
prosecuted and he could go to prison you
know if you look at if you look at this
recent indictment after the Mar-A-Lago
raid I mean this was done what seven
eight months after the special counsel
was appointed they moved that warp speed
to get this done they've had Hunter's
laptop for all these years we know of
low-hanging fruit in terms of of issues
of drug use and crime etc etc but don't
we need a full accounting Senator how
much money did the Biden family do in
business with China Russia Ukraine
Kazakhstan and a dozen other countries
what do we know about these llc's that
the house oversight committee has
discovered you know why did it take so
long to get the suspicious activity
reports why is director Ray well you
know why does it take a threat of
contempt to Congress to get him to
cooperate with the committee that's
charged with oversight on these very
matters
look part of the reason that the FBI and
the doj can be so contemptuous of the
American people is is they believe they
will not be called to account Senate
Democrats certainly don't care about the
answers they don't care whether it is
true or not that Joe Biden received a 5
million dollar bribe from a foreign
National not a single Senate Democrat
asked about that Senate Democrats will
not hold a single hearing on that
question and they know that the
corporate media will will cover it up
and hide you mentioned none of the
corporate media even mentioned the
allegations when when when Joe Biden was
asked at a press conference about it he
laughed and said where's the money you
know what Al Capone said the same thing
he's mocking the American people and and
let me put something else out listen I
don't know whether it is true or false
that Biden in fact took this bribe but
do you know who knows to a hundred
percent certainty
Joe Biden and if it's false he could
call on the FBI he could direct the FBI
hand over the the 1023 hand over the 17
voice recordings because they will
exonerate me they will demonstrate my
innocence he's not doing that instead
his henchmen at doj are stonewalling I
asked the deputy director did you do
anything to investigate these credible
allegations from a trusted informant he
refused to answer that question as well
this is a rogue agency that is
Thoroughly politicized it is Thoroughly
weaponized and and I gotta say look you
contrast that with the Trump indictment
which is utter and complete garbage and
they issue the Trump indictment as this
news about Joe Biden was breaking and
compare and contrast the two with the
Trump indictment there's a complete and
utter double standard if you're going to
indict someone for having classified
documents how about Joe Biden and the
classified documents he had stuck in
just about every orifice of his body he
had stuck in a garage next to his old
Corvette how about Hillary Clinton nope
they won't indict them why because
they're on the team Trump is their enemy
and and I believe to indict a former
president or sitting president the
threshold should be very very high you
know what kind of conduct you should
need to indict a sitting president or a
former president something on the order
of taking a personal bribe of five
million dollars from a foreign National
that meets the threshold this classified
stuff does not Senator we need that
information we need to know how much
money this family did with every one of
these countries and whether or not maybe
that's why China got away with spying on
us maybe that's why they get away with
uh aggressive uh Maneuvers against our
own fighter jets and international
airspace and international waterways
with our Navy uh frightening time
Senator Cruz great job by the way
yesterday we appreciate Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else